it will go down as one of the best
private Equity deals ever over the 19
years they put 226 million in to Weight
Watchers and got 5.37 billion out 4.7
billion of realized profits
[Music]
all right what's up uh we are back and
we got another episode uh we got a guest
here today maytab is here he's a he's a
friend of mine who most people I think
probably probably haven't heard of
unless you're in the DDC world or you're
on Twitter or you know what's going on
in that in that area but uh I want to
introduce you because you're somebody
who a has helped me a bunch with my DDC
brand you like know a bunch of tips and
tricks and hacks and [__] like that so
I'm like I basically have a little
scoreboard in my head and everybody's
attributes are there and in yours it was
like business hacks was like filled up
and then the other thing was that you I
don't know if you listen to the show
regularly but you would send me little
nuggets of like oh you should talk about
this you should talk about this and so I
kind of got confidence I was like oh I
think he's just got his back pocket full
of interesting stories that are off the
beaten path and so I kind of like that
do you listen to the show first let's
start there yeah all the time almost
religiously so Sam I got to shower
podcast
oh that's that's perfect we are the
number one ready to shower podcast of
the country actually millions of men
lather to us so Sam I sent him a picture
of uh the Vancouver show where like the
stadium or like the uh the theater was
filled up and he goes wow oh that's a
lot of virgins and I
that's hilarious so true my fiance
listens to the show religiously too and
she wouldn't use chat GPT when I told
her about it maybe a month or two ago
and you guys mentioned it the other day
and she was sending me screenshots so
you guys caught her using that dude the
dermash Pod I think you're referring to
the darmesh Pod I've been using it all
again after talking to him uh I
implemented a lot of the stuff that he
was talking about man he got me hyped up
also what a lot of people don't realize
this
is darmesh pods always get tons of views
on YouTube and finally Sean like texted
darmachel group chat and was like hey
darmesh what are you uh what are you
doing and he goes oh nothing really and
I go really and he goes well I'm just
doing a few things and he like gave this
like very detailed list of like internet
marketing not hacks but he was like I'm
just like testing like buying ads like
500 here just to test this and then I'm
like responding to comments just like
the small stuff that you wouldn't expect
someone who runs a 20 billion dollar
company to like be killing and it is
very tactical we don't even do it with
it's our own podcast we don't do any of
this stuff like people are like oh the
thumbnail the the title people don't
realize we don't see those we don't
approve those we don't know about those
we're not involved in it uh we don't do
a lot of this stuff that we probably
should but uh you know can't be bothered
to do all that stuff but he did he did
do it they say the devil's in the
details and I ain't trying to hang out
with him
he's the man like he was like oh I'm not
doing anything then he had this like
really long list actually
have you said us phrased it to me the
other day uh I called you and you said a
phrase that I've stole and I've just
been saying all around town I've just
been saying it everywhere even when it's
not really appropriate because I thought
it was so funny Sam I was talking to him
and I was like oh you lived in like or
like you're living in Utah why Utah like
you're aren't you like Canadians and
you're like Indian like what's going on
here and he was like he's like oh yeah
my wife something something and I go I
asked you something about your wife and
he goes he goes yeah you know me he goes
yeah you know uh I look like I got beat
with the ugly stick but somehow I ended
up with an awesome looking wife and I
thought it happens it happens beat with
the ugly stick was so funny I've been
using that everywhere I use it to refer
to my business partner all the time so
oh you take him down with you oh always
yeah he's my go-to I don't know I
Googled him he's pretty handsome how um
how old are you
uh I'm 29. wow I'm really interesting
because he does stuff that like you say
words that um most people don't say so I
I pay attention to vocabulary so for
example in the tech World me and Sam
used to live in San Francisco and uh you
couldn't go outside you couldn't poke
your ear out the window you wouldn't
hear the word ebitda nobody says in San
Francisco nobody knows about it nobody
talks about it it's not a thing but then
when you get into like the cash flow
business kind of world that's all you're
gonna hear a bunch of a bunch of
different people talking about words
that have to do with profits you say a
bunch of other words like uh dividend
recap distressed buyout and he talks
about all these things that I frankly
don't know what they mean what they do
how it works but I know that that you
come from a little different world so
I'm excited because I want to talk about
some ideas from your your neck of the
woods you're part of the business world
that is less of stuff I'm less familiar
with personally and so I think I'm gonna
I'm gonna learn a little bit where where
do you want start what what what topic
should we start are you sent to Doc with
some things I wanna I wanna look at some
of these let's start with one that hold
on Sean I need a little bit of
background here so you you basically uh
I like I read your medium post so if I
understand this correctly uh the name of
your holding company you guys buy into
or you buy entirely outright uh
distressed or D only okay performing d2c
Brands and you make them great is is
that the summary
yeah it's the gist of it and we're less
of a whole tone more of a um an
independent sponsor if that makes sense
and that just means you do everything on
a deal by deal basis so the equity that
you're working with might be very
different on a deal by deal basis that
doesn't make sense I don't understand
what's what do you mean when you say
sponsor so it just means that we're the
ones making the investment and say on
one deal Sean's a co-investor with us
and then on the next deal only Sam's on
the cap table with us and you run it or
you hire CEOs or what
um it depends on the portfolio company
right now I am day to day with one of
our portfolio companies and how many do
you have like seven I think no there's
three platform companies and then
there's another eight to ten kind of
minority equity and depth positions that
we have and the whole thing is roughly
of what size so uh me and listeners
understand
um the core platform companies which is
what I would count as part of the
revenue because we owe the majority of
those companies is warranty figures
um it's kind of that that mid eight
figure range and is the biggest one the
the flowers company no that one's
slightly smaller than the succulent
company but the Flower company is the
one I'm most bullish on that one
solarwood flowers.com and that's just
because
um there's a lot of room for merchant
expansion yet so what's that one that's
the one you talk about the most so so
let's give let's get let's give you said
three platform companies so you said a
succulent company uh solo wood flowers
so it's a like a wood or fake Flower
Company correct made in our other one
that yeah exactly so Made in India
people buy them for like weddings and
things like that right because flowers
are super super expensive at weddings
and so these look really good but they
don't cost as much as fresh flowers or
whatever
what's the third like majority owned
company
um that one's an apparel company
apparel company okay yeah and so
um you own these three let's talk before
we go into the details about each of
these
um I want to know the origin story
because you've told me you've told me
some interesting things like I think you
met your co-founder on Reddit like in a
subreddit yeah yeah and so take us back
uh go all the way to I see hear
something about about getting sick at 17
start there and then tell us the story
of how how you got to this this spot now
when you're 29 years old yeah so quick
and dirty version is essentially uh
diagnosis spinal stenosis and
degenerative test disease when I was 17.
um so that meant you know obviously
doing anything physical
for work was kind of out of the picture
um so I decided to learn more about
e-commerce and Entrepreneurship and just
kind of stumbled
um
I I started a Facebook page called
guitar porn and this is back when
organic reach was awesome you know you
post something people would actually see
it Facebook plus this was so much free
organic reach it was the greatest time
ever
um almost like Tick Tock is now right
and then
um I transitioned I started doing
basically guitar runs like semi-custom
guitar runs with big Brands and we'd
partner with a retailer dealer this is
before Brands would work with you
directly right and we would sell out
these pre-order rounds and basically
take a cut eventually we cut out the
retailer and became the retailer
ourselves uh that got kind of low seven
figures that was nice because there's no
capex so we didn't have to have much
cash right it's all pre-orders
um after that I started a men's hair
product company which is really ironic
because I'm sick
um so I don't cut my hair and I have a
turban and uh so did that with one of my
best friends that also skilled kind of
low seven figures along with the guitar
pedal company that skilled below seven
figures and then after that I decided um
you know these are all fairly small like
Tams really small for Niche guitar
pedals uh so I decided to start
investing realized hey you know no one's
gonna come to me
you weren't even doing guitars you were
doing guitar pedals specifically uh so
the first company was a guitar retailer
like actual full-blown guitars and then
yeah the one that was really profitable
was guitar pedals just because the
margin was insane and I partnered with a
um a guy who had met flipping guitars
like just trading guitars with and he
was a grammy-nominated guitarist right
he is
um he plays at a band called periphery
for any metal nerds and uh that went
well like those were both flowing well
in terms of cash small opportunities
were your products any good or were they
kind of you're just good at the
marketing because that's my that's my
kind of uh rub with a lot of DDC
companies is uh they have pretty shitty
products but slick marketing um what no
the products are awesome I mean I have
like 30 or 40 000 posts in Guitar forums
by the time I was 18. so I really was
into guitar I used to play six to ten
hours a day so I uh I definitely knew
what it took to make a good product so
okay cool yeah I mean like a lot of
these companies like I'll see I'm like
dude these are [__] or like this is some
Alibaba crap that just wrapped up in
something a little bit nicer but it's
still pretty crap like there's no r d
that like made a superior product you
know what I'm saying especially with
like a lot of the Cosmetic stuff like
lotions and stuff I'm like I don't know
man this is kind of crappy so did you go
to college because it sounds like you
were doing these when you were like 18
19 20 21 is that right yeah so I was in
school and then I dropped out
um it just didn't make sense to stay in
school what did your Indian parents
think about that uh they were not they
were not big fans of it that was yeah
what was your like Dropout point was it
like I'm making X dollars and the X was
just like too big or you just didn't
have the time to go to school what why
did you drop out
um it just didn't seem like the value
was there relative to who I was had the
opportunity to interact with on the
business end and
um it just seemed like there was more
opportunity there if that makes sense
then obviously I was doing okay in terms
of cash flow so uh so how old were you
when you majored you know this podcast
called my first million how old were you
when you ended up making your first
million
um in cash or Equity yeah
uh I don't know I'd probably put it in
like mid-20s early 20s like 24 or 25 and
so you you did that through these kind
of like smaller Ecom things and then
how'd you get into this kind of like
private Equity style thing where you go
and you buy these distressed companies
and you turn them around so how did that
happen
yeah so in the Great Recession when I
was a kid reading about it I always
thought it was interesting reading about
private Equity firms that made money no
matter what like if the company did well
or it failed and I thought hey that
sounds great I hate being an
entrepreneur because obviously the
company doesn't do well you fail right
and that's still the case it's not like
you know
um it's just not as black and white
anymore so I started um explain that why
would a why would it make why would it
work whether the company does well or
not does well explain how that works
yeah we can jump into that a little
later but part of our thesis is
essentially investing on how much
liquidity or cash the company can
generate in a short-term basis
um so if you can invest today and pull
most of your cash out within two or
three months there's a lot less risk
right versus say you bootstrap something
new you're always putting more and more
cash
um on the working capital side you need
to fuel growth right if you're doing a
traditional consumer brand that's less
of an issue for something asset like
like SAS right
um but but that's the case then you
don't actually end up pulling cash out
of it for so long so we're where most
people focus on Equity appreciation you
guys focus on liquidity you guys focus
on how quickly can we pull cash out
whereas most business people just think
how do I make this worth more which
often results in putting more cash in is
that correct right and that's just one
facet of it we're okay with holding for
the long term or being more long-term
focused if if it makes sense and
sometimes we're just more of a
short-term partner and like it's not
uncommon for a software company to sell
on the low end for three times revenue
on the high end if it's fast growing 10
times Revenue what you just said was
you're going to buy a company for
basically uh uh uh one-sixth times
because you said you want to get your
cash in I can't do that math but you
want to get your your cash back in two
or three months so you're buying it one
six times profit or cat uh of cash flow
I mean like like nothing so give us give
us a sample deal economics so in a
situation where that happened
yeah so we invested in adult health and
wellness retailer which is a nice way of
saying sex toys
um that's I'm in Utah so you know but
why don't you ever say the name of the
brands because you don't want to you
don't want to talk about it
um well if they're distressed it's just
kind of got it okay um yeah just culture
kind of mean to them so I I'm not like
that but the and I can send them over I
think I shot them over to Sean but
um yeah so we we invested essentially at
um I'd say a fairly far below Market
evaluation just because others were
unwilling to invest in it in that kind
of company and this was 2018 back when
it was a little bit more taboo than it
is now I know there's a few publicly
Venture funded brand book Dame Etc in
that space so it's become more socially
acceptable but we got in Far Below kind
of Market valuation uh give us a give us
a sense so Revenue was about X and then
what was the distress why was it
distressed they had too much inventory
they had a debt problem what was the I
would say it was more of a case of
really bad margins uh and there was a
clear case to improve those margins they
were just originally a drop shipper
they're doing like six million a year
this is one of our first deals so
they're very small they're only doing
six million a year
um and
I'd say market for that for valuation
like the growth Equity side would have
been like
10 15 million as far as valuation back
then we got in it like one and then the
company paid us a royalty until we're
paid back and full of that initial cash
investment and then there's a few other
kind of structural things going in but
we got involved and we helped boot up
their initial why would a company like
that sell for one million dollars I
think that's if I'm listening that's my
question right like yeah he said that
six million and normally that's like 10
million of value but they bought it for
one and how are you are you just Mr
Charming or what why were you able to to
buy it at that price so that one was a
minority Equity investment and we got
involved like really Hands-On
operationally so my co-founder he jumped
in and he helped them boot up their
their physical operations and
transitioned from a drop shipper to
holding their own inventory and booting
up Ops here in Utah
um he helped them launch that facility
make their first few hires GMS Etc and
then I helped them raise
um debt to fuel growth and that kind of
took them from that six to twelve ish
Mark gotcha gotcha okay and then we sold
our Equity
um just five secondaries to a VC firm
that invested later what's that value
been created okay gotcha
um so so continue on so you uh
you've done some of these okay so you
see so I want to go back to to sort of
how did you get this idea so you read
about this you're like all right private
Equity has this trait where they can buy
stuff at a certain price or on certain
terms so that they get their money back
quickly whether they you know their
Equity portion is small uh they have a
lot of debt and they get their money
back quickly uh you read about that but
still you've never done that so how did
you decide to actually go do it how did
you figure out how to do it
yeah so I just started posting on Reddit
um to try and find Initial deal flow and
then I met which club one guy
um just the entrepreneurship one
so I met my co-founder who I still work
with now Alex
um through that subreddit and then I met
a lady who was one of the first few
engineering hires at ubereats um and she
actually ended up retiring like eight
months after we started working together
when Uber ipo'd
um and then the other one was someone
with a very traditional background in
private equity and he's the one who kind
of taught me a lot about private equity
and you're just what building a
relationship through Reddit DMS or like
how are you like I don't meet anyone on
Reddit what is actually happening here
sounds like you met some pretty high
quality people and actually trusted them
enough to partner with them yeah it's
the same way you meet people through
Twitter I guess right
um just posting getting to know people
I'd say that the community there is very
low quality uh on Reddit versus Twitter
and some other private forums like you
know EO IPO uh what Sam has going on
right
um
so there was a lot of filtering to be
done but we did sorts the deal through
that
um that's how the succulent company was
was found
okay gotcha
um
okay so Sam what do you want to do from
here you want to talk a little bit about
this like Flower company thing or you
want to talk about other brands that
that he's got on this list I want to
talk you have you have uh three well
well [__] you have five categories or
four three categories you have
Frameworks you have interesting ideas
and opportunities and then you have
under the radar companies I would like
to start at number one under the radar
companies I read those I read that
reverse order number one under the radar
companies you have things that I've
never heard of
and I like I'm pretty good at finding
these unheard of things
yeah so let's start with a simple one so
tell us about Josh's Frogs yeah like
this is one of these types of companies
this is one of my favorite companies it
says all the characteristics of a
company we'd love to invest in
um and I've been trying to invest in it
since 2018 but he always says no so it's
okay though I still love him so
basically Josh's Frogs does exactly what
it sounds like they
I don't know if you call it farming
breeding they read their own frogs and
their Exotics and they also grow the
bugs that they eat and they sell the
food but they do all that in-house in
Michigan and they ship it to customers
so if Sam wants a frog tomorrow he can
order one from Josh's Frogs and they've
scaled really cleanly totally
bootstrapped Josh is awesome I called
him on a Sunday and the guy was catching
frogs with his kids I couldn't believe
it you know I think he's been doing this
for 15 20 years and uh she's still loves
frogs and frogs basically do you know
the price of a frog I don't know what
frogs are going for dude I'm looking at
it I'm looking at it now I would have
thought like so you could buy a chicken
at track uh Tractor Supply for like five
bucks like a chick or yeah frogs are way
more expensive delicious
yeah I mean they're the frogs here rain
the most expensive one is 400 it looks
like the average one is like 60 to 100
bucks for a frog those are people
they're beautiful but like you know
these are for pets like people want a
pet frog so they go yeah this uh 60
black poisonous dart frog all right it's
fair enough later on you you guys should
watch the tour of his facilities it's
really cool and so you like this
business because what
um so what I what I really like is the
Steep Ops mode so no one else your
typical e-commerce guy is not going to
go out and boot up a frog operation
right
um it's just too intense so they don't
really like physical things we have to
show up a lot of guys just use three PLS
and it requires a lot of specialized
knowledge at the same time you know that
someone oversees is not going to
undercut you and it doesn't become a
race to the bottom with monetized
products because you can't really ship a
live frog from China or directly
overseas to the U.S it's just not viable
thank God so with that there's a very
strong operating mode you're only really
competing against other companies in the
US right
only people weirder than himself which
is yeah exactly only gonna be like three
other dudes yeah you're seeking a cost
per acquisition of customers stays
consistent doesn't really Spike the way
you see it spike in other uh like space
Josh's Frogs Jacks frogs Sam's frogs and
you know Herbert's frogs those are stuff
for the big four in the Frog industry if
you're Josh if you're Josh if you're
Josh from Josh's Frogs what what would
you sell this business for or like what
would be the threshold of okay this is
interesting I'll take the offer or I'll
maybe take the offer
yeah I obviously I can't say what Izzy
but does and if I gave you a multiple I
would kind of tell you what is ebit does
but I would say there's probably
let's say your average g2c business his
size might sell and I'll just use a
range for 8 to 10x she would get a
premium of a few turns on top of that
because of that operations mode and it's
not something I didn't just knock off
right
yeah it's super super defensible uh
okay so and how did you even find this
you know this guy personally or you
found it I beat him I I met him through
uh I did a podcast on e-commerce Fuel
and then he reached out and we just got
along and I I will stay in touch with
him we like to turn it out we have
similar problems for their businesses so
it's fun to discuss them with him like
implementing lean Etc so by the way I
just read uh I just Googled Josh's frog
Revenue so it looks like they're on the
Inc 5000 so you can find it there but
according to some articles they're in
the range of like 15 million dollars a
year in terms of frogs I don't know if
that's accurate and I haven't actually
researched it but that's like just some
top searches that are showing that
that's pretty wild yeah I think they're
they're bigger than that now that's yeah
there's a picture of him on the about
page and he just looks so happy this guy
looks like it's great in frog heaven
right now I'm so happy for this guy just
this one picture just like I I hope to
be as happy as this man right here
um this is a good one I like this and I
think what's cool when you so invent in
in the sort of like Tech world right all
the discussion is always just about like
but the future dream like the dream end
State it's like what could this be if
everything goes great and what I've
learned as I talked to guys like Andrew
Wilkinson or the guys from enduring
Ventures or you people who are buying
who want to buy you know solid stable
cash flowing businesses that are
profitable
um that's not the you know it's not the
pie in the sky sort of thinking that you
get in Silicon Valley and instead
it's basically what could go wrong so
instead of what could go right it's what
could go wrong if I bought this company
and um that's why people love businesses
like this that are that have this like
you know defensibility this moat so it's
like No One's Gonna compete with me not
internationally because you literally
can't ship the Frog locally Mo you know
the average e-commerce bro is Not Gonna
Wanna like take this on
um so who am I competing against I'm
competing against basically nobody which
will let me which means my business is
extremely defensible and so it's just a
different way of thinking that is less
common when it comes to Tech which is
sort of like half-assed can you grow
um you know can this become huge can
this become a Unicorn it's a different
sort of like mindset altogether
um what's another example of an under
the radar business that that's worth
talking about talk about this
fast-growing trees one
I think that one's a great example so
similar similar operations but where
obviously they're kind of growing the
trees again no one wants to be a tree
farmer right so it's not sexy no it's
going to go out and raise Capital to
become a tree farmer right that sounds
kind of neat to me wait so so literally
what what is it they sell seeds or they
sell the actual tree what's going on
both and the company I I first stumbled
across the same way the company was
being sold six or seven years ago and I
think it went for between 100 million to
120 million and it looks like they've
grown quite a bit since then I wouldn't
be surprised if they're worth closer to
double that now just with their website
recall Etc they're very like traffic
estimate shows it went from it's like at
almost three million uniques a month
that's pretty crazy for a free website
their website says uh flower so here's
their H1 flowering trees are it you'd
hate to miss out on the hottest trees of
the Season wouldn't you shop now over
1.5 million happy customers and so what
you see is I I don't know what type of
trade this is but it's like a grown tree
that's purple it does look beautiful it
looks it's a beautiful tree and uh I
just think it's hilarious you uh you'd
hate it
following trees are it that's like you
know like the like gen Z people like he
is him she is her have you seen this
like this trend
trees are it this is awesome I mean it's
a really defensible business it's cool
um kind of no one would really expect
something like that to be that large
right and so what do you buy you buy a
tree that's mostly grown already and
then they come and plant it
I think you plant it I think it shows up
and then you plant it oh my God in your
property so if you want if you want a
tree to like for more privacy you say
privacy Hedges or something similar or
just trees in general this is where you
go how much room do you think they do
your fix
um I have no clue now again I'd be
really surprised if it was less than 100
million in Revenue this is yeah I'd say
probably close to like 150. and what
type of prop what about uh net margins
would this be or net income or ebitda
uh I'd be really surprised if it was
below 20 probably closer to 20 25 this
is crazy and they probably don't they
probably aren't buying too many ads I
they had a couple Google ads but like it
seems I bet you this is the type of
company that they I mean they called
their company fast growing trees for a
reason I imagine that was a search thing
yeah yeah it's an older company it's
been around for a while
um under a few different owners it's
like a private Equity Firm runs it now
and who would have thought that like you
know when the internet came out it's
like yeah people are going to be able to
like buy things online it's like there's
some guy out there who's like they'll
buy trees online it's like no no no no
way no way why would I buy a tree online
that sounds like the most far-fetched
thing and then here we are 100 million
dollars selling fast growing trees
online you could buy this by the way
look at this Italian Cypress it's like
this would be perfect for the Airbnb Sam
yeah I am a bit I'm looking at this and
I think this is pretty awesome like I
like they have some beautiful Hedges
there's like uh fruit trees I mean this
is pretty amazing I understand this I'm
getting to the age now to where I
appreciate a good tree
yeah
yeah this is this is pretty crazy okay I
like this one give us another under the
radar business
yeah um what seems more appealing to you
the first well let's do the Betty's one
and then we've talked about this CSC
generation thing and we should but you
have more info on it than we do so let's
do Betty's and then do the CSC yeah so
Betty's is really interesting business
what I love about it is strong IP mode
so if you go to their website
um
what do they do it's like a bed cover
thing for kids I actually don't know how
to explain it very well
um but it may it's two kids can
basically change the bedding really
easily but
they have it's patented and they have
proper IP mode and when you go to their
website you can tell it's not very
optimized but they've been crushing it
totally bootstrapped great people a very
healthy ebitda margin and
um it's a duvet cover it's a duvet cover
that's easy to zip which I have a zip
duvet cover as well the duvet covers are
a pain in the butt to to do it's meant
for little boys so that makes sense
um
so this they bootstrap this to 40
million that's pretty impressive yeah
I'm pretty sure it's right around there
um yeah that's pretty good and you can
tell it's all pmf like killer product
Market that killer product killer IP
mode and they've done a really good job
with that end of the business what do
you think are some of the like uh I I
don't think this is like a everything
can perfectly do this but I think that
when you like look at like a software
company you think all right so what are
the attributes of like a great software
company that gets scale you think like
well they have to have good net
retention meaning most people come back
constantly uh ideally you can it's
expensive enough product that you could
afford to hire a sales team uh thing
like things like this like there's like
a handful of checklists and then there's
lots of examples of things that don't
check the checklist that still succeed
but what are the handful of of check
boxes that you have when looking at uh
or building a d2c company particularly
things that people don't think are true
like for example like in the cool kid
Circle I mean you're 22 you want to
create like you know cool [__] that gen
Z buys you're none of nothing that
you've mentioned fits in that category
right for us what we found is the most
consistent mode and some people are
different right it's just the moat
that's worked for us is that operating
mode so anything that requires physical
manufacturing has a good reason for the
manufacturing to be in the US or Mexico
is great
um and we found that like I'm not sure
if you guys are familiar with lean
manufacturing um it's just like a
philosophy behind I guess running a
manufacturer operation Toyota thing
right yeah exactly it ports over very
cleanly from company to company but
marketing does not right what worked
with your paid ads for a company with
let's say low aov but really fast
consideration period so you know
something like clothing I see clothing I
buy it's very simple compared to the
marketing side for something with a long
consideration period that's very
different different teams totally
different strategy nothing will really
carry over clearly but on the
manufacturing end it carries over
cleanly company to company to company
um so for us that's that's our favorite
mode so it's summarize you you want a
low consideration period and you want
something that can be made in America
because it has some type of
manufacturing mode anything else well so
we don't actually care about the
consideration period um I think it's
just like an actual challenge then a
vertical you get into right
um if if that's there but for us we only
really care about the manufacturing end
now and then obviously the way we enter
the deal is really important too
um
and that just you know if you pay next
to nothing for something the odds of
making it work and making money on it
are much much higher than if you overpay
on Entry I want to talk about this
agency stuff because you know the
interesting thing about you know people
like you in the DDC world is they're
oftentimes really really good at
acquiring customers because it's kind of
like like the d2c folks oftentimes are
pretty good now before it was the gaming
company so like if you met someone from
a gaming company or from the attack
world like that meant that their
internet marketing chops were like
pretty good now that uh d2c or now that
Facebook is harder to buy ads on the
people who are succeeding oftentimes are
quite good at that and Sean and I have a
bunch of friends who are starting
recruiting companies and right which is
really interesting because recruiting
companies isn't new Outsourcing isn't
new but people are putting sexy new
packaging on it and I guess from what
I'm guessing because you have it on here
is they're doing a really good job or
historically they've done a poor job of
acquiring customers and you want to
apply that to that space is that right
yeah I just think it's a really
interesting face in general but uh I
think some of these agencies are really
heavily focused on say the Philippines
or other countries in Southeast Asia
we've noticed there's a lot higher
quality talent in places like Mexico and
you don't lose
the same negatives associated with
hiring in the Philippines are not there
in Mexico so for example you could build
an office out there and fly out and be
there in person in a few hours if you
live in Texas right and the wage
disparity is not as high as you would
think for really really good talent
you're only paying a large number but
you know it's not actually that bad a 30
more than you would be for someone who's
great in the Philippines maybe 40 more
in Mexico but again you can visit them
in person which is really big you can
have them fly out and again it's big for
us because we do a lot of manufacturing
right so they can actually understand
the product or interact with the team in
person so your retention goes up the
quality of work is much higher and we've
found the quality of applicants is much
much higher in Mexico too so if I did
start an agency it would be focused on
solely Talent Mexico and
um just for example when we're having a
customer service for like a new manager
or director we're getting people who
used to head up Uline are you guys
familiar with Uline
I just use it to buy like boxes yeah we
use it a ton for like the when we had
our warehouse
yeah so their customer service is
awesome but we got one of their former
directors and his salary ask was really
reasonable it's like I think five
thousand dollars a month but his talent
was the equivalent of someone who's two
hundred thousand dollars in the US
foreign
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
yeah do you have one agency ID on here
that I think is a no-brainer which is
site speed so we have this problem with
our store but I think everybody
everybody has this problem like yep
basically if you're selling something on
the Internet one of the easiest levers
the biggest levers you have is your site
speed because if you have a slow loading
thing you're just going to lose traffic
you're going to lose customers
um as you have a slow loading page
you're also going to suffer in terms of
your Google rank because Google takes
into account your your page speed as
well and it's really easy in the Ecom
space to have slow Pages because what
happens is
start with a Shopify store you install
15 plugins just to get your your Shopify
store to do anything because like you
can't basically run a Shopify store just
out of the box you have to you're going
to end up installing a bunch of apps and
each app injects a bunch of code into
your page and even if you delete the app
the code stays there's no like you have
to like manually clean that up which is
kind of insane and probably a business
of its own but basically site speed is a
problem that we I think we've hired
three different folks to try to fix our
site speed and all of them I'm like they
claim to do something I have no idea
really if they're if they're doing a
great job or not
um I don't think that they are because
the next guy comes in and says oh man
your site speed sucks let me fix it so
um so I think this is a this is a a
product that I wish existed and I think
could clean up because it's a it's
clearly accretive to the person but
explain your thinking on it what did I
miss yeah
um so it doesn't really require much in
terms of Dev skill it's not like you
don't have to be great at the dev and to
actually do most of these changes and
it's almost like a checklist that's very
portable company to company to company
it applies very cleanly so for example
changing the order in which your pixels
fire for Google analytics Facebook ads
Etc you can delay some of those very
slightly and dramatically increased site
speed and it won't really hurt the
business that much right um that's just
an example of one quick fix you could do
or certain apps do not compress images
properly so judge B the review app on
Shopify for for a lot of sites um it
does not properly compress images so if
you just apply more compression to those
images your side speed goes up it's a
product display page level or wherever
those reviews are so how would you
acquire new customers for this
um honestly I would probably just just
go
Um as you guys used boat with before
yeah we love it yeah just go to Beltway
full list of websites make sure they're
they're doing a certain amount of
Revenue or at least have meaningful
Revenue coming in
um just cross check that against
um so it shows traffic right like Alexa
or something and
um
from there I think you just can't make
their sight slow right yeah just cold
email I think it's just the way to go
with this if somebody out there wants to
do a site speed a shop just DM me
because this is a no-brainer I'll be
your first customer and I'll help you
get the next 10 because and you can even
just charge this you could charge purely
on contingency too it's really cool
because you can see a black and white
effect yeah if you've done a good job
and again it's really easy to do a good
job it's just nobody specializes in this
for some reason so yeah and it's a
moving Target like uh you'll do it and
then like six to 12 months later they'll
need it again because they've installed
a few more things they hired somebody
who didn't know how to compress images
before putting it up they started using
this new tracking software for hot for
heat maps and then boom now you need it
again because you you've gone exactly a
rank back to a c c rank on these like
these site speed graders that are that
are out there I'm surprised the site
speed graders don't have these agencies
or maybe they do I haven't actually
looked but like does GT Matrix are one
of these companies that have the the
site speed score do they not offer a
button that says by the way we could fix
this for you
no they shut down to your point oh my
god really easy especially if all these
e-commerce sites are on Shopify right
it's very I guess checklist
yeah so that's the other move you should
buy that site you should buy the site
speed site that checks the speed and
then just add this button at the end
that's the agency service to uh to fix
the problem if they don't do that
already that's kind of crazy
um how are you uh how are you balancing
your time it seems like you've got a
bunch of stuff going on and these I mean
you know ideas are worthless but it
seems like a pretty good idea to me when
I hear when I'm hearing this I'm like Ah
that's kind of an interesting I actually
seemed like that has legs you've got a
good Network you could probably spin
something up fairly quickly and scale
nicely uh how are you balancing doing
everything that you're doing
about 15 of my time some of the
investment and they're managing our
minority equity and credit positions and
then the rest of times just spent on the
floral business
um there's a pretty big lever that we're
pulling right now with booting up uh
another operating base like a
manufacturing base in Mexico and that'll
get our eat the data kind of five or six
billion and then from there it's a
pretty good valuation so we just want to
get that over the Hub that I'll probably
slowly phase out but my co-founder is
solely involved in that company and
that's the that's called solo wood
flowers yeah yeah
Sam when I met myself I I heard what he
was doing I was like um
I I told him two things I I think I go
how do I invest in this because uh if
you're willing to go down and move to
Mexico and build your manufacturing
facility you're gonna win like uh Paul
Graham has this uh essay that he wrote
called like schlep and he's basically
describes the guys from stripe
um as being willing to do do the schlep
work and he's like you know and a lot of
businesses there's basically some amount
of schlep that you have to do and for
stripe they had to do all this like
banking stuff that was kind of like
annoying and bureaucratic but they
didn't really view it that way they were
a they were so young they didn't really
know what all was gonna happen they they
didn't really realize how much they
would have to do and B they were just
willing to do it and um and you know you
you are willing to do the schlep like
you're like oh you know you're like I'm
looking for operationally intensive
things that's the opposite of what I'm
interested in I'm like I want the least
operationally intensive thing but I get
why you would want it because it's super
defensible once you have it it's very
valuable once you do it it's very simple
once it's fully
set up if that makes sense once you've
once you have like the best practices
from lean manufacturing running it's
very simple to keep a manufacturer
running versus like a d2c brand that's
really reliant on the marketing end
right yeah exactly and so I told you I
remember being like hey can I invest in
your Mexico thing like your facility
there I think that's a great idea and
then I also told you I was like man I
feel like you play the game on hard mode
you're super smart and uh you are like
I'm gonna go do distressed turnarounds
of d2c businesses that's like
multiplying three hard things together
um and I was like why do you do this you
could just you know there's easier
options and you were like no I like this
I like you know I like playing in the
mud once you get a really good deal you
can't go back I'm Indian I need to get a
good deal I need to get a good price
yeah I think that's actually what it is
I think it's genetic that you're like oh
you know the best deal possible a
company that's burning to the ground
exactly you can get it for nothing
you're also um I'm trying to find it but
so your website really good
um but you have this blog post or you
have a bunch of blog posts on medium so
card Adventures Carter with a k k it
should be on sub stack now I killed the
medium oh well I found it on medium but
um
but yeah it looks like it is also on sub
stack but you're really good with
language so like your thing starts off
with like your first sentence is just
good this is a guide intended to give
distress e-commerce heavy business uh to
give distressed e-commerce heavy
businesses with 10 to 15 million in
Revenue a high level overview of
turnaround management Basics and
resources to dive into that's a great
first sentence you're telling me exactly
what I'm getting and then you do a
really good job of explaining kind of
your background with Alex your
co-founder you say you started up these
things in your early 20s you took uh
passive roles or you sold them and then
you like helped turnaround ice.com which
is now called ice Trends you met on
Reddit uh and then you say we welcome
complex opportunities that others are
unable or unwilling to tackle as a
result we can invest in non-control
Opportunities we can grow quickly uh but
you just basically say oh here's another
good line my team and I are responsive
discreet and avoid pointless formalities
we understand how critical speed is both
in turn around and high growth
environment and we can tell you within
24 hours before a fit and so like you
just do a really good job of being very
crystal clear about what your offering
is and you are direct but you're not
rude and it's just a you have a really
good voice and you also like cite a lot
of the books that you've read so you
talk about turn around corporate
Artistry and you have like a quote from
the book and so anyway your language is
wonderful Sean said he pays attention to
vocabulary so do I you you have really
good words you your and your rhythm is
nice what did you read to kind of come
up with your perspective and uh how did
you how did you become a good writer
you're you're quite good at explaining
complex things
I think we all grew up during the era of
Hardcore I don't know what it was but
for some reason copywriting and being
into copyrighting was really popular
from 2010 to 2013 maybe earlier what did
you uh what did you learn for that or
what did you turn to for that
um one of my friends was just really
into it so I got dragged into it too and
just reading random books I think
there's a compilation of like 100 of the
all-time best sales letters that's back
when like people used to distribute
swipe files and stuff like that right um
so just be honored in a random group and
someone would just distribute it and you
just rip through it and that's kind of
how I picked it up it's good you're
you're very good and what were some of
the other books that you read to learn
this topic because you you learned this
at a very young age yeah it's like
corporate turnaround Artistry is one of
the greatest books ever but it's written
by my mentor Jeff Sands and that guy is
an absolute Beast he's turned around
um a handful of Fairly large nine-figure
Industrials
um like manufacturing companies
everything from bakeries to I think
large restaurants restaurant groups Etc
and that guy is in his 50s I I think I
hope it doesn't kill me if I got that
wrong but and he just he just shows up
so you sound like Lumber Mills Etc he
just shows up and turns the operation
around within six to 12 months absolute
machine and his book gives you
it's probably the most value in a book
that I've read in a really long time
it's just like tip after tip after tip
and you can just take it and apply it
even if your company is not distressed
it'll just use profitability if that
makes sense
um really awesome guys it's a complete
machine I'm convinced you could drop
them into anything and he'll just make
it more profitable in six months and
that's because what what is he uh like
world class at doing what does he do
when you drop him in
um I'd say he's just very fast at making
decisions he doesn't hold back in a lot
of ways running a turnaround is like
running a startup you don't really have
the benefit of sitting around to make
decisions right like you're not going to
hire McKenzie to run a full-blown study
to see if you should do something you're
just gonna go and do it right and maybe
you have some light directional data but
you're not going to wait for a ton of
data and you're not going to run some
crazy qualtric survey right
um you're just going to go out and get
it done and that's that's what he's
really good at it's just taking action
he'll show up for example when he turned
around that that Canadian lumber mill
he's American so he just he moved and
you know came by and he has kids Etc but
he still just moved showed up to a
lumber bill in the middle of nowhere
Canada and turn it around he's got it
done no one else will really do that
right and there's a premium for that
what part of this brings you Joy why are
you doing this other than that it makes
you a lot of money
uh I just say it's really satisfying and
it's fairly repeatable so uh and I think
the speed at which you learn is really
really good right
um and it doesn't require a lot of
equity to keep scaling if that makes
sense so for example you can probably
buy a relatively distressed brand doing
100 million for maybe 10 to 15 million
in equity I uh we had um we're friends
with Moyes and silly Ali so right Moy
started a native deodorant and I was
like Moyes we're in San Francisco why
are you selling deodorant why not like
do software and be normal make more
money and he goes I'm a merchant man I'm
a retailer like this is just it's in my
DNA like I just exactly I make products
and I figure out how to make a merchant
I've been working on these t-shirts uh
I've been working with the T-shirt
designer to do things and now I'm just
on the lookout for these quotables I'm a
merchant that's what he said he goes he
goes I'm a merchant what's that say
it says Carter Cog and then uh this is a
banana that says irr like internal rate
of return that's so funny well and Moyes
also said he goes my second favorite he
goes uh my first favorite phrase in the
English dictionary distressed asset uh
and it was funny but he goes he goes I'm
a merchant man like I and it says I
don't know if it's like a like an
immigrant thing or what it is but like
his because I know their their family
also owns homes like uh lots of single
family homes that they rent out and they
own gas stations and a lot of my Indian
friends and Pakistani friends all do
that they have uh gas stations things
like that and I'm like I don't know man
maybe it's just something in the culture
where you just like you're just geared
towards small business but uh yeah and
like for you is it the product that you
like or is it just like I just like
making stuff something that provides
value and I just like optimizing it for
profit I mean what do you think is
driving you towards us
um yeah it's in distress side it's
really interesting because it's like a
game of chess
um with the existing creditors existing
cap table and kind of figuring out how
to squish it together to make it work
right
um so maybe you have like really angry
senior lender and just convincing them
like hey you know give me the position
at a decent price I'll come in I'll turn
it around and eventually you'll get
right side up or at least you'll make
more than you would just liquidating
these guys and then convincing the guys
that you're getting the company from
because they're often really upset right
like say companies doing 20 or 30
million it's still run by the original
Founders in most cases and they'll be
really emotional about it right
rightfully so right
um so kind of figuring that side out is
really really interesting then obviously
the operating end I I don't like it as
much as my co-founder he really loves
the operating end but uh that can be a
lot of fun too just coming in getting
rid of the bad apples very quickly and
then building out a team and kind of
Reviving the culture there's a story of
um what's the um what's the famous
um the famous hedge fund guy who's
probably in his 90s now but you guys
will know Carl Carl Yeah Carl icon he
tells the story on YouTube YouTube and
he's like I bought this company and it
was not doing great but I thought it
could do great and so we owned like 12
floors uh in this one particular
building and I just went from in one
hour from floor to floor to floor and I
laid off the entire floor and he tells
the story laughing he was like it was
the greatest thing ever
the audience was like why you know
you're ruining jobs and he's like but
I'm making it better like we're gonna
we're gonna have a better outcome and
like I go both ways with that I'm like
well you're kind of just you know
um like these Hedgehog guys I'm like
you're just like an Excel monkey and
you're just like squeezing every juice
you can you're not providing a lot of
value but I do understand the
satisfaction of just like getting
something that's not fulfilling
potential and achieving potential you
know it's exactly you know what story
I'm talking about where you're like yeah
I know the exact one same video did I
get it wrong
no you know that you know that yeah he
goes through four by four and he does
exactly what he said and he's like
glowing with like he's like cried I'm
like Carl you're just like ruining these
people you're blushing
let's get him hot and bothered yeah he's
like I'm getting a semi just laying
these people off
but yeah I guess you're kind of in that
position
a little bit I guess it really depends
on the company right a lot of cases you
have a few really good apples people
left for really passionate about the
company they want to succeed and they're
the last people left and then you have
all these people who are more or less
just leaching losses like the corpse
right
um what do you think about how elon's
done this with Twitter
I think it's great I think a lot of
those people are really self-entitled
and they have no perspective on anything
um in a lot of ways they're kind of like
the modern version of those companies
the 1980s that were really fat and just
overpaying Executives Etc I don't really
feel bad for someone who's making up 100
Grand losing their job right
um it's more so people working Blue
Collar jobs where they're making 40 60
Grand or they're working their ass off
um I definitely don't feel bad for any
software engineer making 300 Grand who's
upset they have to work 10 hours instead
of six I don't disagree with you I just
wish it would be less of an [__] when
he was doing it
you know yeah yeah that was kind of
pointless like I think he made fun of
someone who's disabled or something
that's obviously horrible that's
inappropriate and you mentioned
something about uh being in America and
how like you know you like things that
are in America
when I uh does it ever give you like do
you have any sense of Pride around like
creating American jobs because I know on
your website you said we've created or
saved 200 different jobs in America let
alone overseas are you into like that
whole made in America thing for like the
sense of pride thing or is it strictly
like uh this just this if it makes sense
it makes dollars
yeah I think it it's a mix of both I
think it really does make sense and I'm
I'm Canadian but I'm obviously grateful
for the opportunity that exists in the
US you know Americans just much more
gung-ho about entrepreneurship they're
more willing to write a check and just
get involved um than Canadians are if
you go to Vancouver where I'm from it's
a lot of older real estate families
they're not really willing to write a
check and get into something the way
Americans are they love taking risk and
I really appreciate that about the US
yeah man there's a there's a thing I've
noticed recently about
um what I call like the North Star
formula for for a business and so
um I like when you can boil down a plan
into like a very simple
equation so let me give you an example
um
like Sam with Hampton
um I think I texted you this but I just
said Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand so
you just need 10 000 CEOs who are going
to pay you ten thousand dollars a year
and you have a hundred million dollar
business Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand
so it's like can I provide enough value
or if somebody's willing to pay 10 grand
a year
um and then can I get 10 000 people to
sign up for that value your whole
business comes down to that one equation
Ten Thousand Times Ten Thousand
um when I met uh when we were hanging
out with Andrew Wilkinson I was like how
much Equity did you put into tiny
originally
and
um I think it was something like you
know don't quote me on this but I think
it was something like six million
dollars he's basically turned six
million dollars into like 600 million
dollars just as round numbers and six
million into 600 million if you want to
be the next tiny you can just take that
thing I'm turning six into six hundred
okay how are we gonna do that let's work
backwards from that simple formula well
I think I would need to compound at 45
annually okay how am I gonna do that
well I need to buy businesses on these
terms at these prices right so a formula
can be very instructive we have some
friends that just raised 18 million
dollars where I was like what do you do
with that 18 million and they go we're
just trying to figure out how we could
turn uh or like the goal is take this 18
million of equity and turn it into 10
million a year of free cash flow
it's like okay like that's a a
clarifying equation and
um I'm curious many time for you like in
a best case scenario how will this have
played out so like you you go to the
start uh I don't know how much how much
Equity did you and your co-founder put
in as like your seed Capital to get your
whole business off the ground
um well it's kind of weird for Carter
because we both had a few exits
beforehand like he'd sold a company that
he got a low eight figures um in his
early 20s he'd put a bit of cash but we
put in honestly a couple hundred grand
like two three hundred grand so let's
start making Investments so you and so
and maybe you've put in more over time
I'm not sure but like whatever that yeah
we reinvest everything more or less uh
yeah but like just the out-of-pocket
like initial not not reinvestments from
the proceeds of what you've been doing
but just have you had to take something
out of the checking account or savings
account just to to re to recapitalize
the business in any way or no it was
like 2 300 Grand and then anything else
we put in was reinvestments from what
that two or three hundred grand has made
us
it was reinvestments from what that to
300 Grand that we put in eventually was
okay amazing so you're gonna go from
let's say 300 Grand and like if this all
plays out the way you want um you know
fast forward I don't know 10 years or
however long you plan to kind of do this
what would be the big win for you how
much would the portfolio be worth for
this to be like a you know a home run
outcome for you guys
yeah we are really goal driven um we're
a little bit weird that way but we both
want to tackle increasingly large
distress deals so that's what we get
pleasure from I guess just kind of fun
doing it and we'll just keep doing it
until we don't have fun um so our goal
really is get this floral company I
think can usually get to 100 million in
Top Line
um like our allowable customer
acquisition costs will go up by 30 40
once we finish with a few manufacturing
transitions hold on so you don't you
don't have you're not goal driven what
does that mean I I don't even that's
like not English to me how do you how do
you function without without goals I I
just like to do hood rat stuff just
whatever it's fun right dude he's like
you're like the dominatrix a PE you just
get you just get pleasure you get
pleasure like like oh yeah you like that
yeah that's going down that's my new
LinkedIn subheader
you just love the act man you just you
just like the act of uh you know someone
um uh you you whisper whisper irr into
your ears you're gonna get weak at the
knees well it's just fun because you get
to learn from people like like you too
or hang out with other people that are
really interesting
um and that's really exciting too right
but don't you but don't you don't you
have um like a like a you know ever a
lot of people who get in business they
have like one day I want to make all
this money so I can buy you know a
thousand acres or I want to create a
school that does this or I want to be
able to make sure that everyone in my
family who never has a dream a dream my
initial dream and my co-founders do this
before we met it just turned out we had
like the same Target was to make like
five thousand dollars a month that was
it that's how it starts man that's how
it starts
and then you realize that you know you
know what I've noticed I I have all the
same hold on hold on
dude you didn't start like this I had
the same thing and the goals always
change
but you said when you started you guys
have had wins under your belt so no I
mean before that like oh okay okay like
early on like I did my first thing I was
like I'm gonna be stoked if I make 60
Grand a year okay yeah of course of
course of course but what about now you
know like what's like the what's like
the vision the long-term Vision that you
you that kind of keeps you excited maybe
sometimes sometimes it's buying [__]
giving [__] away helping your family
whatever right I think getting this one
portfolio company the next level uh
either selling it or re-leveraging it to
you know cash and then raising a large
fund is probably like our immediate
short-term goal the next two three years
dude that's when I was in college that's
so not what I thought it was gonna be
sorry go ahead when I was in college uh
one semester me and my my buddy Trevor
and our other friend Dan we we had read
the the card counting book this was
before the movie came out 21 but oh my
God the book Bringing Down the House was
out and um and we were like oh not only
are we gonna count cards we decided to
create an underground Blackjack Club on
campus and so we started preparing and
we were like and because we had read
this card counting book instead of just
doing the obvious thing of being like
cool let's just invite some some friends
over to play Blackjack at low stakes
let's see how it goes and we'll go from
there that's how you would do it if you
had any like any ounce of IQ in your
brain instead we were like okay let's go
buy this like fancy blackjack table okay
cool we now we're in the hole and we've
got this like fancy thing and then let's
run all these practice simulations to
see how bad we could get beat and then
what if somebody comes and count cards
what's our security gonna be we're
worried about all the stuff that didn't
matter and we spent no joke we spent
like the entire semester at college
which is like that semester cost each of
us probably like 40 Grand just to be
there and instead of focusing on the 40
Grand that we put into being there we
were doing this thing and I remember one
night we were calculating we were like
oh my God if we do this we could make
three thousand dollars and then we all
started giggling like like can you
imagine that like we were like dude what
if we made three thousand and we just
think that's a thousand eats and we were
so pumped about this and it was like it
just took over our minds like a mind
virus for for three or four months it
made no sense but it was like you know
it was the humble beginnings of scheming
it was like the it was the first of many
schemes to come with the same group of
people we ended up starting a company
together and and did many more things
together but like that first taste of
the scheme and how hilariously bad your
plan and your goals are like now when I
look back I look back with a lot of
fondness on that
totally yeah it makes sense it's always
very small and then you where you're
like your Bot you bought the safe to
keep the cash before you even had the
cash and the cash never even came and we
never yeah we never even read the ran
the club because we like we were too
worried about getting kicked out of
school because we found out how illegal
it was well basically we had one
simulation where I was the again we were
big into these simulations and I walked
in and I played I lost a hundred dollars
and then I go give me all the money or
I'm gonna tell people about this club I
I was like oh yeah what are we gonna do
if somebody does that like
at point in time somebody could just
literally take all the money because
there's no recourse what are we gonna do
call the cops and tell them that
somebody stole from our illegal gambling
Club
and we're talking about this won't work
before I sold my first company I was
using some type of like mint.com style
service and there was like a thing where
you could manual you know you connect
all your accounts and it shows you your
net worth and whatever and they had this
option where you could manually add
something so I manually added this
really big number and I would log into
this every day like six months in
advance and I'm like
sick this is awesome and I remember like
when the money then actually came in I
was like damn I I kind of like felt most
of that joy in that six months leading
up just like I kind of tricked myself
into already believing this was real the
the simulation kind of gave me like a
lot of the joy uh it's pretty cool you
can kind of like trick yourself into
believing these things are true and you
get a significant amount of satisfaction
from that fake thing compared to the
real thing
yeah you because what people want is the
feeling you don't want the thing if you
ever say oh I really want X to happen
why do you want X
if you if you just keep asking why do
you want that the the obvious answer why
you want anything a relationship uh
money whatever it is to have a six-pack
whatever it's some feeling it's a sense
of accomplishment it's a feeling of
relief of real of less anxiety less
stress whatever it is and then you
realize oh it's not the thing I want
it's the feeling and then you might be
able to get the feeling through
literally like faking it you might be
something much simpler that's not going
to take you you know seven years and a
bunch of Heartache to get there and uh
and also if you've never had that
feeling before even when when that thing
happens it'll be your first time having
that feeling and you'll suck at it which
is why a bunch of people feel after they
get success they get like kind of let
down because the feeling wasn't as great
as they they wanted it to be the
anticipation was better than the result
and the reason isn't because the feeling
is actually a letdown it's because it's
the first time they've let themselves
try that feeling and the muscle is just
very very weak and so uh yeah big big
life tip is to realize like what you
want is the feeling and then start
practice having that on a daily basis
through like much smaller things yeah it
works
um make tab you I'm looking to you on
Twitter you have 5 000 followers I think
that being popular on social media it
doesn't really matter in most all of
business in fact sometimes it's like
negatively correlated to how popular you
are but in your case I at least I know
with Andrew like when he's buying a lot
of companies having some
um like you know it's basically being on
Twitter is a billboard for him so when
he reaches out to someone they're like
oh you know I think I've heard of you
fine let's have a conversation
for how good it seems like you're doing
and how smart you are you're um your
social presence is significantly smaller
is there a reason uh for that no I just
don't really like it
um I I just like to post content about
stuff that I actually care about
um and I'm fairly open and then I guess
too on the distressed side when you're
buying a business they're more of a
forest seller right
um everybody talking to a lot of these
senior lenders if you're working with
it's a lot of guys that are in their 50s
or 60s and they're very conservative
traditional
um like Banker types right they're not
they don't really care about social
media or anything like that so I'm sure
it does help the deal follow the growth
Equity side or buying healthy businesses
but
um I've just never really been into it
yeah I mean you have you have you do
tweet interesting stuff it looks like
what's a Daniel Roth watch it looks like
a pretty fancy fancy nerd about like Neo
vintage and vintage watches and then as
well as some newer Brands but mostly
smaller ones
um it's just kind of it's a lot of it's
like Angel Investing it like if you buy
into an early independent brand which is
just like a watchmaker basically going
at it sometimes they can appreciate in
value significantly and you get a pretty
cool watch for the money plus you
support a small business they'll do
whatever you want so it's like a win-win
yeah your your social media is actually
pretty cool I'm gonna follow you but you
have some interesting stuff but like
compared to some of the stuff you're
doing I know a whole lot of people in
the d2c space that are significantly
bigger than you and are much more of a
little pipsqueak and don't ever walk the
walk like you like you are you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah I know what you
mean
uh leave us with this example of this
Weight Watchers thing so uh explain
explain what happened with Weight
Watchers then we'll wrap up super high
level Weight Watchers was not doing so
well and this guy at this tiny firm not
super small but relatively small he
convinced Oprah to join them and they
absolutely crush it that's the very
high level overview of what he did and
so this guy like what were the numbers
so they what are they buying I'd have to
go pull it out and then I'd have to pull
it up okay
um so how did this guy know Oprah by the
way that sounds like you know oh it's
simple he got Oprah on board that
doesn't sound that easy yeah 2015 Oprah
is uh was a big deal yes that's like
2012 Obama like yeah that's Peak Oprah
so in 2015 he did a deal with Winfrey to
acquire a 10 stake in Weight Watchers
since then the company stock is soared
by almost 600 percent they sold one
billion dollars of Weight Watchers Stock
and Oprah gained at least 400 million so
far okay that's pretty impressive
um
it will go down as one of the best
private Equity deals ever over the 19
years they put 226 million in to Weight
Watchers and got 5.37 billion out 4.7
billion of realized profits
yeah that's pretty good uh that's pretty
good not including the stock that they
still at that scale
but they only bought 10 of it uh um
I thought they bought more I think they
kept buying more over time I thought
they kept deploying more more cash into
it
dude we have to do a pod on Oprah like I
I love her I grew up watching her and
like I I for you know she's 70 now I
just looked her up or she's 68 or
something uh we forget or I forget like
how
big of a baller she is I'm like just
Googling it's like Oprah buys another
Thousand Acres she came from nothing
like she basically you know got got her
net worth space something absolutely
insane
yeah what's what's her story so uh what
what do we know about the beginning of
her story uh born in a really poor town
abused growing up Etc and then
absolutely crushes it and she should run
for president
I would totally I think she I think she
was born in like an abusive family and
like I think I think there was even like
pregnant at 14 or something yeah and I
think that there was some like sexual
assault or some some like some horrible
tragic stuff and then at age 24 I think
she becomes like a weather woman or like
uh like uh whatever they call when
you're a news person but you're not
actually in the office you're like out
on the street yeah um she did that and
then eventually when she's like 32 or 33
she gets a talk show but it's not like a
hit right off the bat but it slowly
starts picking up and then eventually
she like makes some like groundbreaking
deal she did like one of these
groundbreaking deals sort of like
Michael Jordan did with Nike uh what
lucasfilms did with Star Wars where it's
like you know we'll just take a
percentage of The Upside and uh and then
that like turned out to be like one of
the most you know one of the best deals
of all time and it's worked out and you
know she did this all day but people
were very very racist so like now
yes like I think it was out of Nashville
Tennessee uh that she's doing this so in
the South and she kind of killed it we
need a how to take over the world
episode on Oprah what's what's going on
where is our where is our definitive
Oprah episode why have you not done this
already
foreign
I'm on amazon.com buying Oprah biography
is there an open biography I would
totally buy that of course there is
there has to be a I mean she's she's the
best I'm a big fan of her and she like
did this all out of Chicago so I think
she still owns like the penthouse and
the Sears Tower which is like you know
one of the largest buildings in the
world uh but no she's the best you know
I always forget about this it's like I'm
in Austin and there's all these nerds
talking about crystals you know you go
to a therapist and they like recommend a
crystal uh like there's like pretty
woo-woo [__] out here
um she was pretty woo-woo but for some
reason she made it very very likable
like you guys remember that book The
Secret where it's just like it's like if
you think about it enough and like put
it in place in your brain the universe
will grant you this yeah and like she
like would she was talking about that
stuff before an event stuff was even
popular and for some reason when she
does it it's very tasteful other times
my friends do it it looks like you know
they're one of those women wearing like
a Coachella Brown hat uh like you know
and it's not cool
if you're wearing cowboy boots
no vibrant hats for me I'm out if you if
you wear one of those things I'm not
part of this but for some reason when
she does it I'm in well that's what I
want to know like I think the the story
I've heard is like grew up in these
terrible conditions overcame and became
super successful but I literally want to
know like what was the successful part
like uh meaning how did she get her
break and then like what led her what
was she doing was it literally just
better content like was she just that
damn good and dynamic as a talk show
host was it like the Microsoft IBM deal
where they like you know how did
Microsoft take over the world it's like
well they cut this really great deal for
the operating system where they could be
you know with multiple providers at once
and and they use IBM to bootstrap and
that's how they got bigger like it's
like was there like a growth hack was
there a um a smart you know deal that
she struck was it uh the timing because
like you know those show you know cables
started spreading into every home in the
country and like she was one of the top
three shows and just like she got to
surf the cable wave or whatever like I
want to know what actually
led her to the Mega Mega Fame uh what
were the actual those those things it's
not like a simple answer but um that's
what I'm actually curious about because
you could like in the air in the topics
that I know about
um those stories are always the most
interesting
and I feel like when you when I go into
other topics like I was like oh May tab
like what happened he was like oh
started off bad now the best it's like
yeah but act two the middle part uh
that's the part anybody who actually
wants to make [__] happen in their life
you want to focus on act two like
Hollywood focuses on act one and three
right like the the bad origin and then
the the happy ending but it's the
Montage the training montage when like
you go from like scrawny to strong the
training montage that they speed up
through is the part where all the
interesting [__] happens
I already told you Gina I go Billy of
the week on Wednesday
Oprah I'm on it yeah
there's this really cool book
um called messy Middle have you guys
read messy middle it's by uh what's the
uh Scott yeah the most dreamy guy of all
dreamies guys Scott belsi is the man
Scott belski basically started um
so this guy named Scott belski he
started behance which is uh where
developer designers could host their
portfolio he started it bootstrapped it
had 175 million dollar exit before it
became very successful he said he had
like 50 000 and he invested like 15 000
into Pinterest at a three million
valuation 15 000 into Uber at a three
million valuation each of those you know
50 to 100 million dollar outcome plus he
owned 75 of his company when it sold for
175 million dollars so very very
successful and now he's it's looking
like he's going to become the next CEO
of adobe so huge deal he's got this
awesome book called the messy middle and
it talks about how like you know
starting things can be somewhat easy but
once you start that then there's uh once
you you start it and then there's the
middle and you have the end and the
end's the kind of the easy part you know
things are just kind of working but the
messy middle is that 10-year period
where it's like is this working is this
not working it's a really cool book on
how to like navigate that period and
it's and and I love that title the messy
middle yeah great Idol great guy he came
on the Pod once a long time ago we
should bring him back um
but yeah he's on your like Mount
Rushmore of dreamy dudes I feel like uh
you've got huberman up there you got
belski who else it's basically like men
yeah yeah
jaw lines yeah yeah you need a you need
a good jawline and a clear-cut jaw dude
have you seen Scott belski's jaw man
he's got a strong I know what I'm
Googling yeah
talk about it talk about not a
distressed asset
chisel yeah that's a blue chip stock
right there yeah he also just dresses
well and I feel like dressing well is
this like really easy thing to do that
nobody does and uh and he does an
amazing job of it especially in Tech I
know he's he he's the man because he
lives in New York dude all those guys
are stylish he lives in New York yeah so
he's got that leg up
um dude I've never been to his house
but I've been to his house I know
exactly what a guy like dad's house
looks like it's basically I can picture
it so clearly in my mind of how
Immaculate like the design is of that
guy's house he invested in the hustle he
wrote a very small check and I've got
the paperwork for where to send the docs
to immediately I looked up and I like
and I could tell you I could tell you
all fair it's exactly what you're
describing you didn't even you didn't
even describe it although the big words
and it's exactly
I tried to uh in 2018
I stumbled across the hustle like this
is awesome I should try to invest in
this so I messaged you on Facebook but
no reply so
it's just kind of funny
this is your revenge no I'm sorry sorry
it's kind of funny if I would have died
that would have been a good investment
but
it would have I'm sorry you and maybe
you would have known Scott you know I
could have helped you connect with my
with my boyfriend Scott maybe you two
could have Zillow
we're friendly we're not friends
I've Googled his house he's not Googled
mine
yeah I can tell you what type of couch
he has though
um but dude thanks for coming on thank
you you're awesome I'm gonna go and find
that I just pulled up Facebook I'm gonna
find that message it's just kind of
funny it's from 2018 it's like hey uh
I'm an angel investor please let me
invest
[Laughter]
here does your last name start with you
okay if you just type in BHL
uh yeah I see it sorry see good deal
flow would have been there I should have
messaged you more you should have asked
you dude I saw a um a post on Reddit
yesterday it was a map I don't know if
this might be fake news but it's the top
it was like one of the most popular
popular posts on Reddit yesterday it's a
heat map that shows the average life to
life expectancy by
town and there's literally a 20-year age
difference between like New York uh
California versus like decisive
um it's like you know people in the
South are dying at like 60 something and
people on the coast who are living like
you know sort of the yoga and salads
lifestyle are living till they're 80 on
average and and then you can see these
small Pockets like in Florida
it's like the retirement community where
people like migrate into yeah
the Jewish New Yorkers who moved down
there they're living for a long time
everything around it is surrounded by
The Walking Dead of people who are gonna
die at 60 something and uh there's like
it's like Boca Raton kills it and then
like George Lauderdale is like as a
30-year uh shorter life expectancy I I
asked my data guy I said please overlay
the map of Chick-fil-A's and it was a
perfect sequence to like
to the dying early crowd which is
unfortunate for me because I love
Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A is not healthy oh we're
screwed
um dude thanks for doing this we
appreciate you yeah Lawrence thank you
[Music]